greetings my name is don
alexander and i'm president and managing
director of gene
cota professional and executive search
our firm connects outstanding firms in
the life sciences
industry with executives who help bring
game changing products to the market
before we get started today i wanted to
take the opportunity to thank
lab roots drug discovery and development
for hosting this virtual
event code 19 has changed the way
companies
operate the way employees perform their
work in the way
both are adapting to this environment
in this session we'll cover both macro
industry trends
and specific changes enabling attendees
to gain a holistic perspective
in this presentation you're going to
learn about
the current life sciences job market
best practices in recruitment
interviewing and hiring
employee and candidate sentiment
and what i call the new normal landscape
so let's begin with an overview of the
current life sciences job market
our firm produces a quarterly report
called life sciences pulse
a link to this complementary report can
be found at the bottom of this slide
the life sciences pulse report depicts
all online job
postings or advertisements for the life
sciences sector
in the united states over the past three
years
including trending patterns and sector
sub-components please note that we will
begin
charging a fee for this report in the
second quarter of this year but you can
presently download a copy
and be grandfathered in for future
releases at no charge
online ads are a leading indicator
in employment in the hiring cycle
as such sector posting data provides
meaningful market activity and direction
that can assist business leaders in the
life sciences industry
to make informed decisions regarding
human capital
so let's talk a little bit about our
methods
of data collection and analysis
in this report so data contained in this
report was sourced from a company called
mz or emsi
mz compiles an extensive sweep of all
online posted positions or ads in the us
on a monthly basis with the ability to
review
up to four years of prior data
mz data is derived from quarterly
updates
of 18 billion data points curated from
dozens of government data sources as
well as hundreds of millions of online
job
postings with filters by company
job title skills keywords
and more offering a wealth of insight
into the us life sciences labor market
i think it's also important to speak
about the u.s life sciences sector
overview
and definition mz categorizes
industries by leveraging the north
american
industry classification system code
or what's commonly referred to as naix
while nax codes are considered the most
reliable source of data
and industry classification in the
united states
there are occasions where industries may
be over-represented
or under-represented based on
industry definitions these issues most
often occur
where there's an attempt to capture high
technology
or emerging growth segments of markets
that are not
as clearly defined as say mature
industries
to accurately define the u.s life
sciences sector
based on product development gene coda
consulted the
teconomy bio investment
innovation and job creation in a growing
u.s
biosciences industry 2018 report
for guidance and then reviewed the focus
set of 24 nex
codes found in that report we then
adjusted to
15 ax codes which are listed in our
report
and deal principally with the product
development side of the industry
today we're going to be reviewing the
fourth quarter of 2020's
numbers the fourth quarter report hasn't
been released yet
but it will be available at the
beginning of february
so with that let's take a look
the slide you're now looking at is a
picture of all posted ads
in our definition of the life sciences
industry
on a quarterly year-over-year basis
with the current quarter labeled in blue
and the same quarter in the prior year
in red when reviewing figure one
we note that employers posted 537
9882 ads in the life sciences sector
in q4 of 2020 and that's up from
492 606 ads
in q3 of 2020.
we see that q4 of 2020 represented
an approximate 14 percent
year-over-year growth or increase in ads
posted in the sector
which was really quite frankly
remarkable growth
as you look at the quarterly comparisons
please also note that the second quarter
of 2020 represented the first
full quarter of results in the pandemic
time frame so when koba began
each successive quarter since q2
of 2020 has moved you'll notice in a
stepwise
upwardly fashion denoting a quarter
where hiring took a pause in q2
and then resumed its upward trajec
trajectory rather
so in this particular slide and picture
we'll take a look at some of the
sub-sector components
that make up the life sciences industry
from le from left to right rather the
red bar graph
rtm stands for research
testing and medical laboratories
the blue bar graph pmm
stands for pharmaceutical medicine
manufacturing
and finally the green bar stands for
medical devices
and equipment when you add these three
sub sectors together they make up the
entire life sciences industry
as we've defined it in the report
we also find that for our audience it's
helpful to think about some of the
industry companies or names logos if you
will
that make up each sub sector so
rtm for instance example companies might
include
laboratory corporation of america quest
iqvia and covants
pmm sector example companies
would include pfizer johnson and johnson
abbvie and merck and finally
the mde sector companies might include
thermo fisher scientific medtronic
striker and donahue
so what insights and conclusions can we
draw about the state
of the life sciences job market
number one the life sciences job market
has recovered significantly
since the second quarter of 2020 when
the
covet 19 pandemic really truly began
q4 of 2020 was the second highest
quarterly tally
in the last three years so a significant
comeback
in q4 of this year
the medical device segment or mde
skyrocketed forward a stunning 27
percent
from the third quarter of 2020
the pharmaceutical and medicine
manufacturing or pmm
segments and the rtm or research testing
and medical
lab segments each had healthy gains
of about five percent each over this
third quarter as well
so what do we expect near term at a
grassroots level
we're now seeing several companies
adding key staff
several companies we have spoken with
are resuming hiring
that may have been delayed during the
pandemic
which will result in more near-term
competition for talent
and ultimately higher industry wages
although coded spread continues to
remain a significant variable
with the election season now behind us
our expectation in q1 is for modest
growth
we expect modest upside in the pmm
segment more significant relative growth
in the rtm segment and maybe a little
bit of cooling off
a quarter in the mde segment from the q4
2020 time frame after all it's hard to
beat a 20 plus percent uh quarterly gain
[Music]
so next when we consider advice for
candidates who may be actively
interviewing
the boy scouts of america motto be
prepared
comes to mind we suggest
number one practice and rehearsal of
both
video interviews as well as potential
presentations
ask a friend to set up a mock interview
and give you feedback
for example secondly
we want to make sure and check all of
our technology
check mics and video cam operations
including lighting as well as internet
connectivity
and application download of the given
technology
such as zoom and do this ahead of an
interview to minimize
the possibility of disruption
thirdly we want to always dress
appropriately
for a zoom interview after all it is an
in-person interview
we also suggest the use of a virtual
background or professional home
office setting so companies we find
tend to be more forgiving in video
interviewing
given our present circumstances
but we do think that one still needs to
be cognizant of what a background
looks like or what their background
looks like as well as making
every effort to minimize the chances for
disruption such as the dogs barking in
the background
if you believe a potential disruption
might occur let the interview know
as things begin and explain how you've
been able to make the shift
from or to rather working from home
in spite of potential distractions
now also don't forget to turn off mobile
phones or computer sounds
that may be disruptive
also and we'll see this more i think as
the 2021 year progresses
i would note on this that we haven't
seen
or had a candidate travel request really
from a client
since this past march but i have asked
candidates if they are willing to meet
in person
on client request assuming cdc
guidelines
are followed as well
but do be cognizant that as the year
progresses
as the vaccine is manufactured and
distributed more broadly
that we may begin to resume in-person
interviewing i think that's important to
to think about
so um when we consider how the need to
uh work remotely has
changed hiring practices or selection
criteria for candidates
we note that more companies may seek
insight on how candidates have
effectively managed
their work from home situations
especially if they
haven't been accustomed to this in the
past
companies might inquire about the
environment in which one
has worked is this been primarily office
based
you know again precovered and asked
about
how an individual's managed to adjust
to a holy or primarily work from home
environment for example a client might
ask
if i understand correctly you've been
working from a home office exclusively
over the past six months to which you
might respond
and then you know what has been your
biggest challenge
in making that transition and what have
you done
to overcome this challenge
those are the kinds of questions that we
may see
in some of the interviews that we'll be
participating in
now with respect to employee and
candidate sentiment
we've seen a few key themes develop
during the pandemic
first and foremost people are not likely
to
relocate during the pandemic
so preparation for remote work
initially and subsequent relocation
is important to contemplate for both
employers
and employees alike
second people that are employed today
are less likely to be probing the
marketplace right now
and tend to be more settled into their
current work environment
therefore thinking about proactive
outreach becomes
very important when considering passive
job seekers
third in terms of understanding
work-life
balance we would encourage employers to
understand that
candidates and employees have now
established a
rhythm if you will that works for them
and works for their family
so if they make a change this could be
disruptive
it's important to understand what this
change
might look like from a new employee's
point of view
finally we are seeing that companies who
provide
flexibility on the site
work from home different requirements
different scenarios
but we're finding that the more flexible
that the client employer is the better
able
they are to attract talent
now when we think about the new normal
and kind of what this might look like in
terms of recruiting
hiring and onboarding we're really
seeing several
key themes emerge
the new normal for recruiting and hiring
will include a candidate's ability to
both interview
and work remotely
and you know that's going to be for
a company's ability to help manage this
new normal
for recruiting we're seeing the an
increased
use i suppose of virtual job fairs
as well as the use of various types of
videos
that would be shared with candidates
for onboarding we're also seeing key
themes such as
potential temperature checks and cova
testing
for on-site work again this is
organizationally dependent
but being aware that one's temperature
may be checked
and that one may be subject to coveted
testing
requirements is important we're also
seeing
the use of tools like docusign used to
onboard employees in a more efficient
manner
and we're also seeing that employers are
leveraging
digital tools handbooks and information
for training purposes since a new
employee
can't readily ask their neighbor you
know quite as easily these days
you know all the way in in really what
i guess we're starting to see occur and
this is what i would really consider to
be
a sea change in the work environment
is that many companies will accelerate
their ability to hire candidates no
matter where they're located
and we've already seen over the past few
years a trend in this area but covet and
the use of these video technologies has
really
accelerated this trend although there
may be
preference or requirements in some cases
for candidates
to be located in specific areas for
specific reasons such as being in the
same time zone
or having to physically come in to a lab
to perform various experiments
companies and employers alike will be
able to hire a much broader pool
of candidates which is really good for
both parties
a recent zillow article stated that
a switch to more telework could give
1.92 million u.s renters or
four and a half percent of renter
households
the option to leave the metropolitan
areas
where they currently live and buy a you
know a starter home in a cheaper
locale and that close to
half of u.s workers
are in occupations in which teleworkings
at least theoretically feasible the less
than a quarter of these workers
actually telework so a lot of room
to continue this trend so a ramification
of this new normal
will be migrations from higher cost of
living
metropolitan areas and we're already
really seeing this now
microsoft for example recently announced
that
it is allowing more of its employees to
work from home permanently
and managers can approve permanent
remote work
as companies in the tech industry follow
suit with microsoft and others
i wouldn't think that it would be long
before the remote work
framework encompasses a wider swath
of the life sciences sector
so finally i want to thank you for your
time
in attending this session and hope that
you enjoy the rest of the lab roots
drug discovery and development virtual
event